hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game that was played in
1977 uh and it was played
via a telex machine now uh for those of
you who are
not familiar with the telex machine as
you are probably probably younger to
know
what it is that this is a telex machine
and i'm just going to read a
a short uh description of it uh for from
wikipedia so you understand what it is
so basically
uh it's uh the telux network was a
customer to customer switched network of
teleprinters
similar to a telephone network using
telegraph grade connect
connecting circuits for two-way
text-based messages telex was a major
method
of sending written messages
electronically between businesses in the
post-world war ii period
and its usage went into decline as the
fax machine grew in popularities in the
1980s so this is the
uh the technology that was used to play
out this game so i don't think there was
a time format involved
it was probably when when you receive a
move then you at some point reply with a
move maybe
maybe you had a like a one day uh to
reply with a move or maybe it was some
sort of a time control we we have no
uh information on that but it's a really
cool game so i do hope you guys are
going to enjoy it like i said it was
played in 1977
and both of them are younger than they
are in this
photo here uh kasparov was 14 when this
game was played and guy west was 19 but
this is the only photo i could find
so i'm using this one and today uh guy
west is an international master and also
a former australian champion
uh i don't know his uh his skill level
at a time the game was played but like i
said it's
it's a it's a wonderful game so let's
check it out
uh so kasparov had the white pieces and
he opened with e4
sorry about that we have c5 so
the sicilian defense is on the board we
have knight f3 and now
knight to f6 usually you'll see
something like a knight c6 d6
e6 but knight to f6 is also very very
playable you attack the e4 pawn
but it's not all that popular today we
have knight c3 defending the e4 and now
e6 and now kasparov opens up the
position like you would
against the normal sicilian with the d4
so captures captures and now comes
bishop to b for the so-called pin
variation as you are uh
threatening to pick up the pawn here as
the knight is pinned so here kasparov
advances his pawn to e5 challenging the
knight here
and now knights to d5 with threats of uh
just winning material here so kasparov
needs to defend on c3
with bishop to d2 now the knight is
nicely defended twice and here
uh west trades we have knight captures
and b
captures of course caspar i'm not
interested in trading the dark square
bishops as well
uh as uh he's saying my next move is
queen to g4
probably i'm gonna uh try and do some
damage there so you could uh
retreat your bishop to c5 you could
retreat it to e7 to f8
uh you know almost like if it was an
evans gambit bishop
but it's not all that impressive c5 is
possible but you always uh
you always are going to have problems
with this queen the g4 bishop the e7 is
no different
queen g4 and it's not all that clear
what you're going to do because if
castles then just bishop h6 is uh
almost winning here not not much for you
to do there
there's a threat of checkmate you have
to give up the rook here white could
even continue attacking with h4h5
just a very very difficult position for
black to play so here
if you if you look at this position
bishop back to f8 was played
and now uh kasparov just plays bishop to
d3 so
he continues development his bishop is
very nicely attacking the king side
he's ready to castle the rook has a nice
semi-open b file so his position is uh
really awesome
whereas black still needs to start
developing his pieces
and if you put this game to an engine
the engine will say yeah white is
slightly better
uh but from a human's perspective uh you
are down
in development so much and even even if
this is somehow playable
if you like know all the all the lines
it's very very difficult from uh from a
human standpoint
and uh especially for 1977 where you
know
the development was everything so here
d6 was played challenging that pawn
and now kasparov defends with queen to
e2 and
it is as of this move that this position
has never been reached again so we're
only on move 10
but the game doesn't last for much
longer because like we said
uh black has none of the pieces
developed
and now he should either capture the
pawn he should start developing with
bishop to e7 maybe try and castle their
knight not there but knight to c6 is
also a possibility
however he played knight to d7 and this
really allows kasparov to
execute a beautiful combination uh
specifically because of the knight
a d7 move so feel free to pause the
video and win this game for kasparov
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on uh you know
just uh
brilliantly sacrificing your pieces and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show
it's knight captures on e6 and here
there's just no reply uh
for from black because whatever you do
is just bad
the queen is under attack and you have
to do something about that uh so what
can you do
uh well let's try well let's first try
capturing the knight
if we just capture the knight can we do
that not really because of this queen to
h6 uh queen to h5 check and the bishop
covering g6
is extremely important here because you
don't have a good move here if king e7
just bishop the g5 check and there is
not much you can do knight f6
you're gonna go captures captures and
now this incredible bishop captures on
f6 uh
because well after king captures queen
h4 and the king cannot
go back to defend the queen you have to
move the king and then white just wins
the queen
as of course the the king is not a
knight so after the king moves just
captures and it's game over
another thing after f captures on e6 and
queen h5 check
you don't have to of course move the
king you could block with g6
but then just white continues happily
sacrificing bishop captures h captures
and captures and that's just it we reach
a very similar position
bishop g5 check and now it's all over
knight f6 check
queen captures and the queen will now
fall uh due to
this double attack that will happen here
king d7 captures
and the king is getting checkmated very
soon so
uh obviously capturing the knight is a
no-go so what can we do we could move
the queen let's say queen to b6 or maybe
queen to h4 even
but queen to h4 loses terribly to bishop
to g5
and now you either lose the queen or you
have to move the queen somewhere and
there are no good squares for example
queen to
a4 is the only square possible but then
just knights the c7 is checkmate
as the king is in check and this bishop
nicely covers this entire diagonal
so these two options are not happening
so captures in queen to h4
not possible so here uh guy west played
queen to b6 uh but it's not much better
so even though you probably know what
kasparov played here
for those of you don't feel free to
pause the video once again and win the
game for kasparov
in the e simplest possible way while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on continuing to
happily sacrifice pieces
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's knight to c7 check
and after this knight to c7 check on
move 12 guy west resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh whatever you do
you just lose terribly because if the if
the knight is captured
then just well e captures on d6 delivers
check
and you will lose the queen on c7 so
that's of course not a possibility
another thing after knight to c7 uh you
could move the king let's say king to
somewhere king to these uh d8 but then
just knight captures an a8 and you
you've lost you've lost a rook not much
you can do here
there there's no good way for even
trying to recapture the knight
and well black's entire position is just
busted you still have no development the
king
has lost castling privileges it will be
a a very one-sided game
and uh lastly but not leastly after
knight to c7 check
you could go king to e7 but that just
runs into a discovery
as the queen and king occupied e file so
just captures on d6
and we have a very quick checkmate king
captures bishop to f4 check the king has
a very few squares to go to
king to c5 and now queen to e3 with
check king c6 and bishop to e4 check now
ends the game as there are no more
squares for the
uh for the black king the knight covers
the b5 square
and uh and that's it uh so
uh that's uh the game only 11 moves
sorry
only 12 moves tonight the c7 check is
the 12th move where guy was resigned and
this beautiful beautiful game was
accomplished uh via a telex machine
let's not forget and for those of you
who are older subscribers to the channel
you might remember
me showing this game i've showed it some
i believe four years ago but
back then we didn't have the photos of
the players we didn't have any
additional knowledge about the telex
machine
and such so i do hope you enjoyed this
uh this remake and of course uh every
remake we make of older videos is now
at 60 frames per second uh so
that's uh the game i do hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank
mystery person jesse berstrom uh daniel
harbor
david kimura and michelle alexandre del
air for contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
and uh a very short announcement uh most
likely
like 95 percent likely we will have a
live stream today there's going to be a
tournament i'm not saying what kind of
tournament it's going to be
uh maybe it's going to be an evans
gambit exclusive tournament to see how
you guys uh you know
uh soaked in all that extra evan's
gambit knowledge but we'll see how it
goes
uh so if i uh make such a tournament i
will
send you guys an invite via via some
sort of uh
not via telex but uh i'm probably gonna
use youtube
uh so yeah thank you all and i will see
you soon